musique tous les lundis soir une
personnalité nous fera part de son coup
de coeur pour un album ce soir c'est un
militant mais où il ya un militant de
l'art lyrique qui a la parole écoutez le
pour moi c'est un monument
guerre et paix de serge prokofiev
c'est son opéra majeur je pense dirigé
par rostropovitch qui ne se présente pas
et mais qui fut un ami de propre fief et
pour qui cet enregistrement est une
oeuvre filiale en quelque sorte s'est
inspiré du roman de tolstoï c'est-à-dire
un monument de la littérature mondiale
et c'est chanté par une des plus belles
basse actuelle du monde bulgare nicolas
12 ms c'est magnifique
il
faut savoir que ça prokofiev
il l'a fait en grande partie pendant la
guerre c'est à dire que veulent compter
patriotique
la vie qui va inspirer aussi c'est la
grande tradition de la musique pour lui
c'est évident